health scrutiny
committee
um
could just start by um reminding
everybody if they would and use the
microphones it's particularly important
for the
web
that the microphones are used for
people beyond this room to be able to to
hear us properly
and um
also
would you um when you
if you speak of um
when you speak for the first time would
you introduce yourself
we do have some media attendance today
that just would like to make sure they
get everybody's names
right
okay
um so um item one on the agenda is
attendances and we do have
apologies from councillor lester
i think there are
some others not to attend not here as
yet so i don't know if we have any more
apologies
and i think councillor slater chair
sorry
i think councillor slater isn't
attending tonight
okay so we may well have some late
arrivals for that's fine
as long as they are able to join us
and there's counselor hartley so
okay
so item 2 is the
committee membership for the municipal
year
2223 so we're asked to note the
membership including the appointment of
my of myself as chair
and the vice chair has agreed at full
council
can we note that
thank you
and item three is the committee terms of
reference for this year as well
we can note that
thank you
and for the minutes of the meeting held
on the 9th of march can we agree those
as a true record
thank you
and
item five uh questions from the public
there haven't been any questions
submitted
item six is declarations of interest so
if members would give notice of any
interest and the nature of that interest
relating to any item on the agenda in
accordance with the
adopted council code of conduct
okay
so that brings us to
sorry yes you do
i'm a trustee of tdaf
i'm an nhs worker sorry nhs worker but
not in trafford
okay introducing myself as councillor
jane brophy my declaration is i work for
the nhs at manchester foundation trust
thank you
deals with that then
um
so item seven then is uh
altering a minor injuries unit
if i could just introduce this by saying
i was
keen that we put this on the agenda
today because of local concern
about the
minor injuries unit i know that um
the nhs would would have
preferred it to be dealt with later in
in our year but i did want to at least
kick it off
at this meeting so
it won't
as we see from the report and
um probably from
what we discussed it will be a matter
that um comes up again very very soon
um
but uh we'll make be making a start with
it
today
and
who we got
um john waring director of strategy from
manchester university foundation trust
um hopefully the the paper's fairly
self-explanatory i know it's it's brief
um but as um the chair said um we're in
the process we're about to embark on
undertaking an options appraisal um
around them
the the current temporary suspension um
such that we can seek to open reopen the
minor injuries unit as soon as possible
um
clearly the background to this i'm sure
you're all aware of um
the the covid um pandemic um the focus
that we needed to have in ensuring that
services remain safe
and particular pressures we had around
our workforce and those have remained
and but we feel we're now in a position
having discussed it with the ccg in
particular and we can undertake this
option appraisal as planned during july
and august with a view and very much the
commitment to the organization to ensure
that we reopen
the minor injuries units as soon as
practically possible in a safe and
effective fashion
i'm happy to take any questions i know
it's appreciate it's a a short a short
paper
thank you
yes
i'm councillor akila akinola uh just a
quick question do we know what kind of
impact it's had on other services
other emergency care services all um
we haven't looked at that specifically i
don't know if the ccg have known me
yeah we can share some details of that
with with the committee afterwards i can
share the information but um the
majority of activity that goes through
altering minor injuries is um fractures
and breaks and and they dispersed into
other um services across mft
within show which is just on the border
of trafford general so we can get the
numbers and the figures and changes that
had a significant impact on any then do
you know so it
i mean
it will have had an impact in the terms
of fact in in terms of activity but
that's the um strategy that mft have
taken around redeploying the staff and
supporting that within shop
councillor taylor
thank you chair um having read the
information that you've provided as well
thank you very much it seems that one of
the major barriers to
reopening the minor injuries unit is a
lack of staff particularly advanced
nurse practitioners um are you able to
tell us what measures you've taken
either to recruit those professionals or
have you explored any other
um
groups of healthcare professionals that
may be able to
take on some of those roles
thank you thank you yes we've been in
active recruitment it's a particularly
um difficult group of staff because
they're highly specialized and we have
also undertaken some training and it
takes about um best part of two years to
train the staff so we have been in the
process of putting people through
training so hopefully they will come
through with a at a reasonable rate
okay have you explored all the groups of
professionals for example um allied
health professionals who might be able
to
um undertake any of those roles or i'd
have to come back to you on on that
particular question okay thank you
council lloyd
well it's only a comment um really first
of all
um
last
time we were here we had to wait for
information to come
it's
it doesn't require much imagination to
know what kind of questions we're going
to ask
so uh kayla's question um about the
impacts on it
yeah that would be my that was my
question as well
and i just think it's a bit frustrating
to have
information after the meeting as opposed
to actually at the meeting because we
can then interrogate a bit more
and that makes our job as scrutineers a
bit easier
thank you
dan eaton
[Music]
thank you chair and and i do take the
frustrations i think what we are
certainly proposing that this comes back
as part of a bigger piece of the urgent
care strategy there's an awful lot of
change going on at the moment with the
integrated um
health and social care system which is
one of the papers tonight
and also um
we've got a lot of uh demand changes
with elective care recovery plans etc so
i think this needs to be seen in the
context of that wider piece which was
why suggested a slightly later date but
we appreciate that obviously something
was requested tonight we want to to make
sure that you know the options
appraisals are being completed
okay council acton
yeah i think it's um
a worrying situation that we have here
um
and
you know
in the paragraph that says what happens
next we will continue with our
recruitment attempts but we
we require options in the event that we
do not succeed
i'd like to know the options um
but
i i'm i'm worried really about
how long this is going to take
because as
my colleague has said
um you know the knock-on effect an
impact you know
can be very severe
um because obviously there's pressures
in in all the hospitals as far as i can
see
um so
d do you
you know do you envisage whether
there is a date where we could get back
to some kind of normality
i think that's the the purpose of the
option appraisal exercise that we're
taking place to ensure that what
whatever we do
can be done in a safe and effective
fashion that's well that's our first
priority here um so the work we're going
to do over july and august as it says in
the paper as i think we've described
previously we'll set out um the sorts of
things that we can do
um the constraints that we've got and
and and how we proceed from there and
that's what we'll bring back to you um
at subsequent meeting
council mrs young
basically
people who attend altringham general
general minor injuries don't just come
from the
south trafford area now that the metro
has opened people from all over trafford
who are on the
metro line very often find it more
convenient to come down to waltringham
if they can get treated there rather
than have to get on a couple of buses to
go to trafford general or to go to with
inshore or the mri or wherever and i was
almost wondering if you can't get
the actual
emergency nurse practitioners that
you're
actually looking for
could you not run it with people who are
maybe not quite so highly qualified but
who would be able to make
somebody who walks in any walking
wounded that go in there you'd be able
to make them comfortable and then send
them on
to a
proper a a all-functioning a e and i
mean
i had somebody come to me
quite recently who lived in
stratford
and she had gone to
tried to get herself the traffic general
because she put her hand down on a hot
plate and had badly burnt fingers and
there was something like a seven hour
wait
that she was told when she got there and
she ended up walking out and going to a
pharmacy and letting the pharmacist
treat her and i think that's the sort of
thing we want to avoid because as far as
possible if somebody really is bad is
injured they should be able to do you
see what i'm getting at actually
i do see i do see what you're getting i
think the that
our starting point is to say is that
whatever we provide whatever um
a facility would provide whatever
services required have to be be safe and
effective and of course
um
one of the things that that often is a
challenge is is people going to one
place and having to go then having to go
to another place so we want to make sure
that there's clarity in terms of what
people can expect and why they need to
why they would go to a particular place
versus another and i think that's one of
the things that in particular work on
the strategy um
that's that diane was describing needs
to to be clear about is
what are the access points and how do
people access urgent care in a way
that's safe and effective as i say so
they know that they can go to the right
place get treated and then that's that's
their journey over and done with us as
as practically as possible
and counselor hartley
thank you chair um
so i'd just like to explore where um the
proposal is that we you know we continue
with the
enp recruitment attempts and
i'm trying to get an idea as to whether
that is life to be successful or not um
so i know in in the second paragraph of
the report it says that there's a
national challenge in recruiting to
these posts
um
so i guess my question is to unpick what
that problem is so what what is the
nature of that national challenge is it
is it pay is it nurses leaving the
profession is it
um
nurses not doing the training to become
an emp you know i guess
i'm probably a little bit ignorant as to
how one becomes an emp but
i guess if we understand the nature of
that national challenge that will
probably tell us whether your further
attempts at recruitment are likely to
succeed or not
i think it's a range of factors um
people choosing what to do it's a it's a
it's a skilled job and requires
additional training
um and people can make decisions about
where they go and work there is a
shortage of them nationally probably
because we're not training enough um for
all sorts of reasons um so
the the strategy of trying to attract
people through a variety of means um
that we us as an employer versus uh
sorry as well as um trying to grow our
own workforce is the sort of approach
we've been trying to take and that's not
unique to this particular challenge
thank you
naomi ledwards
it was just to follow on from john's
comments and diane's i think it's a
commitment for us as a locality team to
come back to scrutiny with the detail
that everybody's asked for
i think there's there's kind of two bits
to it there's what mft can do safely and
um able to recruit in terms of staff and
then there's the wider urgent care
strategy and the needs of the population
and answering the questions that you
asked where the you know what were the
needs of the patients that have attended
altering minor injuries where have they
flowed to what's the impact that has had
um and is there a better way that we can
organize ourselves so that we can flow
in a in a much better way
we know that we've had
feedback from patients that um it's
confusing in terms of entry points into
urgent care within traffic because
there's there's a number of entry points
so something about simplifying it your
story about someone trying to go to
trafford and then being signposted to a
pharmacy actually if the pharmacy was
the best place for them they're not
saying it was in that case to be able to
signpost in the first place to the
pharmacy would be much more helpful as a
as a member of the public so i think
it's our commitment to kind of we have
to have an answer to this by by august
about where where we're going so it's
our commitment to come back with mft's
approach but coached in the wider urgent
care strategy that will clearly show
the the needs of the population and and
the activity that was going through
object and minor injuries as well as all
the other areas in terms of urgent care
and access points
and i think there's something as well
about how we communicate that because
there's lots of access points for um for
urgent care as well as a single point
and to direct people into that as well
so i hope that helps chair just to be
able to give you a bit more clarity
counselor lloyd
can i just ask um because um it was
mentioned as the seven hour wage at
trafford general
are people using the one one one service
to be directed to that and what impact
has that had on on numbers again um
getting people to the right place at the
right time
so
the numbers precise numbers of the top
of my head counselor lloyd i'll have to
follow up with you but um
we have got one one one which is either
accessed by a telephone or via an
internet which in trafford we have an
additional service
um that can hear and treat people over
the telephone and support them so
there's a higher proportion of people
being managed and
appropriately as well out of choice over
the telephone or through video
consultations um through that service
and then also directing to traffic
generals so the number of of people that
are foot falling into trafford general
has actually decreased because of that
and and we're getting really good
feedback about the support that the the
more digital services is supporting and
we've also got kind of
two delivery points at the front door at
trafford general we've got two different
providers working alongside side by side
with each other so we're looking at how
we can do that more efficiently to be
able to improve that access as well
and
i think
i mean it's more operational probably
for john or one of his colleagues to to
answer as well the
the the quote of kind of a seven-hour
wait at trafford general will be at a
point in time and i'm sure that will
fluctuate depending on workforce and
activity that goes through as well so
again we can give you a bit of a track
of kind of what the average is and the
peaks and troughs we we don't want
people waiting a long time for urgent
care we want to make it as simple as
possible um
but it's
demand has gone up
and we need to find a way to be able to
make that simple for people to be able
to access in the constraints of
workforce and and well safety is not
constrained but mindful of making sure
that we keep everything safe as well
diane eaton
um i was just naming a question really
to support the members of the committee
have we got a really clear process that
any information from residents or from
members around particular examples of
difficult access et cetera are fed back
into yourself is there an inbox or
something that people
can send things so just make sure you've
got all the intelligence as you're
building these options appraisal thank
you so
um
what i what i am doing with the team is
looking at any kind of formal complaints
or pals issues that we've had through
but there isn't a specific inbox around
it but we could work with that i'm
linking to colleagues at mft around it
as well because um it is about the
feedback from residents that we we need
to respond to yeah because we could be
missing quite vital intelligence
otherwise couldn't away from
particularly from members because
residents often do share with members
their concerns
thank you
okay i think we've had some um
some good in
sorry sorry cancer
i just wanted to follow up on on um
diane's question actually so i think i
think yeah as local councillors we can
um gather that data and we can gather
that information and feed it back to you
but
is that data not already available to
you um
so it from trafford general and and
mri people are turning up there with
minor injuries particularly those that
might live close to altering them and
therefore might go to altering them if
it was open so
has there been any analysis of
that data and how long those people are
waiting if they go to trafford general
if they go through mri thank you
so that information is available i know
from what we've looked at in terms of
the ccg which is slightly separate to
mri we haven't had any complaints or any
formal complaints come through from
anybody about access
what we can do is pick up the
conversation with the pals team i think
at mft because that's slightly more
informal than compliance and we can do
that analysis
yeah just to from a complaints
perspective again we've had nothing
through um formally in terms of access
issues particularly with respect to to
the monumentaries unit um but again
we'll do another check just to make sure
that's still correct
okay thank you um if i could just
then conclude decide to with a couple of
comments from from myself
um
i think from the contributions from the
committee it shows it was right to to
get it on the agenda today and i do
appreciate the point that
you know
the options are being
uh looked at but i think this probably
helps i know in those options options
being considered
the the information that
you know the committee has put forward
to today
um
there is a nervousness amongst the
public and i think the fact that so many
councillors of the committee have spoken
the way they have
um endorses that that point
um
altering them is um
several miles from the other locations
that that are options for somebody who
is in need of some some help
um anecdotally i had experience of
within short and e not so very long ago
that was um
shouting a nine hour wait as she went
through the doors on a scrolling message
um so if i'd have walked in there with a
burnt hand
as the uh
um example that um
we heard uh i don't know how i would
have felt uh to see that before somebody
had actually
looked at my situation
so people do worry and
then in terms of
altering them hospital itself and the
minor injuries unit they become
suspicious
when it's closed
and then rumor fills the void
and that's something that
i think we do need to be mindful of and
and it would be
it would be good to see some assurances
uh
going out some form of communications
going out
um to the public
and that would
at least give them some comfort
um so
with that those points i'll uh i think
can conclude this this item but thank
you everybody for for your input
into it
[Music]
so item 8
then is the integrated care system
this is to consider the
presentation which has been
distributed to us
thanks sure good evening colleagues uh
my name is thomas maloney i'm a program
director across health and care for the
ccg
um for the next few days at least until
it transfers to the icb uh inside
um and uh trafford council so uh here on
behalf of sarah radcliff who couldn't
make it tonight is the joint council
officer um what you have in the paper is
quite a detailed um
update from the last update i think we
did in march which takes you through
what is a readiness assessment for
traffic as a locality in terms of what
we have in place um for day one and on
all the the work that we've done to to
close down or will close down the
statutory organization of the ccg in the
coming days
hopefully it provides assurance and i'll
pick out a few key points from the
detailed paper
about how we have got that readiness
assessment in place and all those core
components that we need as a trafford
locality in order to be effective um on
day one
i think before i just move into some of
the detail i think um some catch-all
statements will be we are in the best
possible place we we can be given some
of the uncertainty from greater
manchester and some of the lateness in
some of the decision making but we are
in a really positive place we do have
and the six teams of the ccg
transferring over on the 1st of july the
senior leadership team still providing
that leadership for that team
and
we have a number of arrangements
particularly in terms of our shadow
governance uh coming into effect in
terms of reference being agreed um if
they aren't already so i think we are in
a really good place this is a really
challenging time for people particularly
those who are um nhs employees and there
are informal and formal changes no doubt
in the coming months and years ahead and
that people are having to deal with and
work through particularly more functions
than others where it makes sense to to
make changes at a greater manchester
level and but i think um the system has
wrapped around the ccg and supported it
extremely well over this uh of what has
been uh you know a changing 12 months
and an emerging landscape
um
just to pick out a few key points from
the report then and then we can spend
most of the time on the discussion in
questions and we do have our local
governance in place now i think we we
did report a scrutiny committee on a
number of occasions now around the
provider collaborative board the
trafford clinical and practitioner
senate that we have stood up um
excuse me and the locality board that
sits sits across that and i think they
are the key components that gm as an ask
needed us to put in place for our new
trafford integrated care partnership as
it's now being referred to
and
hopefully acting upon some of the
feedback and questions we got at the
committee back in march i think there
was a question around clarity on some of
the governance and what we had in place
here in trafford and hopefully the
governance diagram within the paper
starts to articulate some of those new
arrangements that we have and the
connections between those different
groups
and what is also in that paper is those
six teams that i referred to as before
are the six functions of the ccg and how
they will be moving across into the new
system
and very importantly under the
leadership of the place based leader and
again since the last time that we met as
a committee um sarah todd as the chief
executive local authority has been
appointed that place base lead which i
think is a fantastic appointment
for the trafford system
we are still just in the throes of
figuring out and going through the phase
four process of appointing what's called
the delivery lead um or the deputy place
base leader as some areas are referring
to it so those arrangements are a live
conversation and hopefully will be
concluded by the end of next week and so
we have holding arrangements in place
next week with gareth james who's the
joint accountable officer to do that
holding arrangement for next week
whilst those agreements get in place
in terms of the locality board i think a
real positive traffic is that that has
been in existence now for over 12 months
probably about 14 15 months that has now
been operating as a trafford system
um as a multi-part multi-partner forum
that really is driving that strategy
from a trafford locality perspective the
terms of reference we will be taking
into the july board and there's a slight
update from once this paper was written
about the roles responsibilities and and
the format of that locality board so
very much in line with what we said
previously it is a consultative
forum but we have uh built into and will
build into in due course the section 75
committee containing the ccg and the
council's
section 75 agreements and again that is
just being finalized as we speak and in
due course it will move across from the
health and well being board is the
intention into the scope of the trafford
locality board
we're actively having conversations
around the co-chairing arrangements and
i think the feedback we've had from uh
from partners is that balance between
local government and the nhs is
absolutely pivotal it's drove in our
relationships and built our
relationships over the previous years
and we want to continue that into the
new chairing arrangements so a subgroup
that we have a working group um is
building up some options uh with a view
to putting a preference forward at the
july meeting at the locality board for
agreement in july uh council andrew
weston will will chair the locality
board um and hopefully we will agree
those arrangements furthermore
other pertinent updates from a provider
collaborative perspective and delivery
of our big priorities in trafford um
we've completed that exercise and there
are two really big ticket items um which
we won't have time to go into detail now
about a high level uh revolve
around the discharge to assess in that
resilient discharge to assess program uh
but also our neighborhood model and that
is one of the cornerstones of our
locality plan all the way back from 2019
and very much um still the cornerstone
of the refresh version that we did at
the back end of 2021
and progress is being fed through the
board there and again holding ourselves
to account on those system metrics and
whether or not we are making a
difference also worth noting to the
committee that we did commission using
some existing resource david filling um
uh to help us with an operational
effectiveness review of the provider
collaborative board
and that has uh
turned out a series of recommendations
which the board are actively discussing
and will be doing on thursday this week
uh and and some of those again revolve
around uh holding ourselves to
accountable system metrics and now we
achieving the outcomes that we want to
achieve
in terms of clinical and care
professional leadership we have our
clinical senate uh clinical and
practitioner senate should i say uh up
and running with a draft terms of
reference which will be looked at in
more detail following the agreement of
the locality board
and a draft work plan has been aligned
uh to the work of the provider
collaborative board so that it can
dedicate the right people organizations
clinicians practitioners to the
priorities that we've set as a provider
collaborative and to make sure that that
clinical and practitioner insight is
embedded throughout the planning design
and delivery of our services across
health and care
really positively as well is the
standing up of the trafford gp board and
naomi's much more of a an expert on on
this in particular but that is a really
good um uh step forward in terms of how
primary care is coming together at a
trafford level um and very very recently
those terms of reference and a chair
have been agreed but very much still in
its infancy and wanting to see how that
connects into the rest of the health and
social care system for er excellent
progress nevertheless
i touched on the neighbourhood program
before and that's articulated within the
paper in terms of all those key
components and it's not just the health
and social care element but very much
that broad arena working with giller and
public health colleagues around how that
connects into the bcfse sector
and we have our living well in my
community forum which drives that work
forward
and you'll see that the building blocks
in there are much broader than just
health and social care but very much
pinned on that wider inclusive uh growth
an asset-based approach that we
i think do very well in trafford on
and i won't go too much into the detail
of the population health system element
of this because i think that's captured
within the majority of the next paper on
tackling inequalities but just to
reinforce that sort of really pivotal
role the health and well-being board and
the review that we're undergoing there
to make sure that that has that real
focus on tackling inequalities and again
the way in which we prioritized our
provider club to board um big ticket
items for the remainder of this year um
was absolutely through that lens of how
can we make a difference and reduce
those health inequalities that we have
as a system and that have been made even
more prominent through the effects of
covert
um
in terms of innovation discovery and
spread this may seem maybe a little bit
more light touch than other areas
of
the response of the readiness statement
but i do believe that the local digital
leadership that we have in place has
enabled us to be a real sort of um a
player for us of a better phrase an
influential voice within that greater
manchester space and it's backed up and
reinforced in trafford's digital
strategy and the fact we have pan
locality arrangements with manchester um
in terms of that governance and that
digital agenda through the manchester
and trafford board i think is really
positive progress given the footprint of
mft and in particular the local care
organization and so they are really
joint conversations and obviously um
there are real benefits to greater
manchester integrated care system uh
being a a live and living and breathing
thing as of july the first because there
will be opportunities um uh from a
digital perspective
um
i think
in in summary um
this has been a really difficult time um
with the lots of challenges along the
way and lots of uncertainty and i think
the way in which the traffic system has
come together uh to ensure that we have
the right leadership in place the right
governance in place but ultimately the
partnerships that have evolved um ever
more since colby i think has proved that
this has been a joint effort i think as
soon as we can
agree the delivery lead i think that
moves us on to the next stage
and the next year will be a year of
transformation i think that's been very
clear in the comms that have gone out to
the system um but as a trafford system
we will come together will we use our
governance and our partnerships and
relationships to make the best
of that that we possibly can
and i'm just going to hand over to julie
if i can just to cover some of the sort
of technicalities and what is a massive
effort in terms of closing down the
clinical commissioning group in trafford
um so julie if i can hand over to you
thank you
yeah thanks tom um so i'm julie flanagan
i'm the interim chief finance officer at
ccg
and i've been the senior responsible
officer for the closed down program so
just just to update we have undertaken a
robust due diligence process using the
national checklist um
we took that through we took the
governing body through that that
document in detail um in late may ahead
of um
an assurance letter to the chief exec or
chief exec designate of
great manchester united cairn that came
from the joint accountable officers and
included the checklist there's been
external assurance provided on the
process were undertaken by mersey
internal audit agency
and our checklist has also been reviewed
by um the legal firm supporting greater
manchester partnership as well
um so so we're in a good place in terms
of closed down as as
um as tom's alluded to in terms of and
the setup for the integrated cats
integrated care system
um so we've continued with the due
diligence work even though you know sort
of into june because obviously things
can move on there will be a
items that remain open as at the 30th of
june and will be transferring into the
icb
and this week we'll be submitting the
strategic and corporate risks from the
ccg that will form part of the overall
risks for the icb as we go forward and
any further information that they
require subsequent to what we've already
shared with them but at this moment in
time there's nothing further that
they've asked for and i'm happy to take
any questions on closed down ccg
okay thank you
can you
yes
gilbert
um
my question is um well first off well
done for doing it with only a three
month delay i think that's um no mean
feat given the circumstances um but i
guess my question is about potential
impact on patients and will they have a
seamless experience because i guess
listening we've just spoken about minor
injuries unit we know waiting lists are
behind we know that we've got issues
with access to gp surgeries in some
areas and i guess my you know this is
almost the perfect storm in the wake of
having this as well are there any
services which potentially could be at
risk um through that transition or will
patients not even notice that that this
has happened
so it should absolutely be the latter um
absolutely and now we may want to go in
on particular services etc um
but this
the arrangements and and the pre-work
that we have done for day one should
mean that this is a seamless transition
services will continue there is no
everyone from a ccg perspective with an
nhs contract goes across
on the employment commitment which i
think we've fed back here previously and
obviously what the future holds in the
transformation and the levels of
delegation between greater manchester
and the locality in some cases still
needs to play through the system uh
there are still some appointments to be
made at a greater manchester level at
that chief level that will have
particular responsibilities um
and the governance handbook becomes a
thing on the first of july which
includes that gm operating model and its
associated governance um so i think
in the in the immediate term absolutely
not services should continue the quality
improvement sorry continuous improvement
should i say of services will absolutely
be retained everyone is being retained
in the locality at this moment in time
to continue to work on those functions
that the ccg provides so people
shouldn't see a difference
but as i said there will be a larger
more transformational piece of work that
will need to be enacted um in the coming
months and years i would imagine
thank you counselor acton
thank you chair
i think my uh question really is about
the workforce um
clearly this is massive change we know
that and we recognize
that and um you know and it's welcome
change as far as i'm concerned um but
um
you know the workforce is critical and
you know
in my experience
when you get change
it's it's quite difficult uh for for the
staff to
understand that change and
and and how we actually bring them
together
in terms of making them part of the
the whole system change
so i just wonder how you're actually
prepared to do that
and
again colleagues may wish to come in on
this but a couple of things probably to
come back on that particular question so
you're absolutely right this has been a
difficult time for colleagues and no
doubt it will be as we do more
transformation into the future and
things uh things will change inevitably
i think there is a real um clear
supportive program at a greater
manchester level around keeping
colleagues connected across the whole of
the nhs and beyond as well into our
partners um
particularly in local authorities where
there's lots of integrated arrangements
across greater manchester um and there
is a series of webinars support and
supervision available through a
centralized program in greater
manchester
which has had positive feedback i think
locally as a as a ccg there's been a lot
of
communication and and that again has
been really well received from
colleagues
with regular kitchen briefings with
regular newsletters with again detailed
supervision between different teams
directorates etc um
and big time out together sessions to
think about what does this mean for us
and our different teams and in
particular a little bit of sort of
looking into the future as to what those
potential impacts may be on particular
functions where it does maybe make sense
to have more sort of gm centric
approaches um but again that's all part
and parcel of that open communication
that i think the ccg has put in place
over the last and it takes more than 12
months i think since the white paper got
announced and so i think that is a real
positive plus the gm work
um i don't know there's anything other
than that you want to
know
i don't think so tom i think the the key
bit really has been we've been holding
weekly briefings um internally to all
the staff and any any
information that we we have from gm
meetings that we attended are all shared
with the staff so they're as as briefed
and up-to-date as they possibly can be
but as you've said you know change
always creates a level of
anxiety and there's not much we can do
about that but we have tried our best to
keep everybody abreast
damn you wanted to come in
thank you chair and i i just wanted to
say this is a massive a massive change
for the system um across health and
social care but especially for our ccg
colleagues and i'd just like to
personally thank everybody for working
with us as partners in the development
in the planning in the thinking things
through together which has left us in a
position where i think we've got as much
certainty as we can in a massive system
change and but they've done that with
such integrity
and caring and partnership i would just
really like committee to note that and
thank you
thank you and
sophie you wanted to come in
thank you that's really good to hear
that you've found this to be a really
positive experience and as my colleague
has already said you know well done on
executing a huge piece of work it's like
turning around a ship isn't it in a uh
in a very short space of time i just
wanted to ask a couple of questions just
to understand a little bit more detail
really about the trafford provider
collaborative board i have decided to
try on this document quite
uh it's weighty isn't it to to wave my
way through but um just about the
function of that because you said it's
about um really sort of bringing people
together and having this collaborative
board and um i always ask this question
do you have any um i know you've got lay
people on the ccg but as are there any
opportunity for lay people to be
involved in that particular uh body at
all
sorry a bit of a comment
so um
to come back on the first part of that
question so um yeah apologies it is
quite it can be a dry document sometimes
when there's this level until it's dry
it's just it's just dense there's a lot
to take it's not it's not dry it's
interesting um
uh so
um the provided collaborative board is
one of those core components that
greater manchester and other regional
systems have has to be put in place at a
locality level uh we did previously have
what was referred to as the local care
alliance which has evolved into our
provider collaborative board and diane
is his co-chair of that provider
collaborative board and you may wish to
come in in a second and
the provider collaborative board is
currently made up of uh
partners from across our health and
social care system and beyond um and uh
it it doesn't have any lay members on at
the moment
it has got it has got it
it has got heather to apologize
healthwatch um
and we um
but we have got a draft and working
terms of reference so when the locality
board terms of reference is agreed and
clarity
is sought there in terms of levels of
delegation i think that is a point at
which the log the provider collaborative
board will re-look at its terms of
reference as will the um practitioner
and clinical
center and as is alluded to in the paper
we have now refined our priorities for
the upcoming year
and using a steering group that sits
underneath it to progress a number of
other partnership uh prioritized pieces
of work um but
yeah that's probably
thank you very much
another question
thank you can you just give us a little
bit more information about the um
digital ambition i can see it you know
it's very far-reaching ambition but the
reality is i work in the nhs and and you
know obviously implementing digital
approaches is really really important
isn't it but i do see that a lot of
people still struggle to engage with the
digital
you know digital services really so
um i'm probably not the best person to
come back on the detail of the digital
strategy but i'm sure paul james our
joint chief digital officer would be
more than happy to put a more detailed
brief together in terms of the strategy
i suppose
my understanding and knowledge at this
point in time would be how that strategy
sits within and enables the health and
social care reform that we've got in
terms of the detail i'm afraid i'd have
to come go back to you on some of that
i'm afraid
yes
heather and just to confirm that
healthwatch has been
very welcomed within the ccg and the
local authority
and we have sat on all of the main
boards for about the past 15 months so
you know the public does have a voice um
and we submit reports regularly uh to
the uh to the boards and letting them
know what the public's concerns are but
so far i think that
everybody locally uh has to be
congratulated because it's gone
i think as smoothly as it's possible to
be and having gone through about four of
these reorganizations personally
i think it's probably the um
well the most effectively um been
carried out really so thanks
chelsea hartley
thank you chad i wanted to ask a
question about conflicts of interest so
one of the problems which people
anticipated with ccgs and which which
did materialize in some in some ways was
was that conflict of interest between
gps uh being members of the ccg and
being involved in the governance of the
ccg and then the potential for their
practice to benefit from those
arrangements um i'm not aware of any
instances in trafford but i know there
were instances elsewhere where that that
did happen um
do you think this transition to an ics
reduces the potential for those
conflicts of interest or
does it worsen it and
to
because i know that clinicians will play
a role in the governance of the ics so
beyond the
um
practitioner senate i think there's a
mention of a clinician chairing the
locality board as well so
it's clear that clinicians will feature
in the governance to an extent so
what uh
sort of safeguards or audit has been
done on the
potential for conflicts of interest so
as to avoid that thank you
i might not be able to come back on on
some of the finer detail of that however
we are taking uh legal advice and have
done uh from hill dickinson um for a
number of months now in terms of that
terms of reference for the locality
board and therefore what
responsibilities and roles does it have
to vote in rights et cetera conflict
resolution um we have a meeting
literally this friday to go through the
detail and that's with colleagues from
mft from gmh and from our primary care
networks as well with graham who's the
representative on the locality board to
do that piece of work um
so i think and pending further advice
from hill dickinson building on the
previous two sets of advice and that
will be captured within the final terms
of reference which will go to the
locality board i think the way in which
we have set up our system um
[Music]
and the relationships that have been
built
i don't foresee there being any
conflicts of interest which would go
above and beyond what we would
experience now as a clinical
commissioning group um that would cause
us any issues um but obviously we have
to plan for our plan for our
eventualities um and uh and and i think
that would be part of that legal advice
that we would take and i'm sure as the
governance handbook gets finalized in
this next 24 hours for greater
manchester that will have that scheme of
delegation the relationships between
subcommittees it's a great manchester
level and the governance that we have
here in terms of our local shadow
governance which may again evolve over
the coming uh months and years um once
the sort of place based leader sarah and
the delivery get appointed on their feet
under the table and really understand
what they want in terms of the traffic
governance
a couple of questions for myself if if i
may um i noticed in the in the paper
there's quite a number of um
bodies meeting for uh
um mentioned has anybody compared the
number of such bodies
being set up
compared to the outgoing system
i just wonder if it just
seemed to be coming over as a bit for a
heavy and i just wonder if that is the
case or is it just status quo
um
i would say what where
it's a good observation um
there are i think instances where over
the last 18 months we've created forums
to enhance that partnership working
across health and social care and some
of that was put in place off the back of
the locality plan that was agreed
in 2019 and some of those groups still
remain in a part of that governance
chart and diagram that you see in the in
the paper today
um
however
i think one of the recommendations
funnily enough from the operational
effectiveness review of the provider
collaborative board said we do need to
take stock once the transfer has
happened the ccg has closed down to
understand whether or not we're working
in an efficient way and that each forum
that you see on on the um the diagram
and which is described within this paper
is adding value to the system um
and i think there will inevitably be a
review and we've had we've held a line
throughout all of the shadow period that
the governance that we have in place
remains flexible and we will act as a
system to either
slim that down if we think it needs to
be slimmed down and done in a different
way or we'll maintain the existing
infrastructure that we do have so i
think it is very much a live
conversation and some of it somewhat
dependent on what greater manchester rig
are in terms of their final governance
again which should
be relatively clear on day one through
the uh the publication of the the
governance handbook
thank you and and julie my ears pricked
up when
i think you said about the due diligence
there's still some open items um with
not long to go in
the commercial world of mergers and
acquisitions that
due diligence can sometimes
yield a deal breaker so
are you able to assure us that is not
the case yes certainly so so the the
open items would be things like freedom
of information requests that we receive
so obviously we can receive a food
information request right up until
thursday of this week so that won't that
will be something that will be an open
item that will be closed as we've moved
into the icb they're items that we will
hand over effectively but
we will retain locally and and respond
to so those kind of items that we've got
on the due diligence checklist where we
list the number of areas which are still
open um and will be a response completed
post the 30th of june but we've done
full due diligence of what we've gotten
and should
the gm partnership asks for any
information in terms of those we've got
everything uh identified and
and stored so so it's there but but we
can't we can't formally close everything
because there will be things that will
be coming in right up
the 30th of june
and i'll preface my last
question with the
with the remark that i wouldn't know
where to begin in trying to do what
you'd done and they're still still doing
so my question is uh
are you still having sleepless nights or
do you feel everything is uh in as good
a shape as
um could be expected
[Music]
and again the latter i think um i i
think given where we are now uh so close
to uh to transfer the amount of work
that's gone on and as i said not just in
the ccg but the support that partners
have placed in in all the partnership
forums that we that we have and i think
we are in the best possible position
there's obviously a slight delay in the
appointing
of the delivery lead but i don't think
we're alone there in greater manchester
and holidays haven't helped et cetera so
um i think as soon as that's there i
think that will provide real assurance
and clarity for staff at a locality
level uh those six ccg teams those
functions that are moving across into
integrated manchester integrated care
system so um yeah as positive as it can
be i think sure
i don't know if anyone's got anything to
add
okay well i'm seeing smiling faces so um
and positive words so that's that's all
good
anything from anybody else before we
move on then okay thank you thank you
very much
for that
um
so item nine is the equalities
strategy and to consider the
attached report
thank you chair naomi and i are going to
speak to this item jointly uh i'll start
by introducing myself i'm gillibergia
salan and i'm a consultant in public
health
it's a comprehensive set of slides that
you have there so we're really just
going to pull out a few headlines for
you and key points and then there'll be
time for discussion and questions
health inequalities are avoidable and
systematic differences in health between
different groups of people
and we all know that the pandemic has
not only exposed but also exacerbated
those inequalities locally and
nationally and indeed globally
just one local example
alcohol mortality in trafford increased
by 50 percent between 2019 and 2020.
we know that inequalities damage lives
but they damage all of our lives it's
bad for everybody when there are
inequalities in society not just those
at the bottom of the social gradient
so um it's clear that health
inequalities are a top priority
obviously for the council for the nhs
and for the wider system
and it's important to note that it is
those
social economic and environmental
factors the cultural and political
factors that we call the social
determinants of health that actually
drive
health inequalities those are the things
that make it easier or harder for all of
us to choose to live a healthy life
and we often think about geographical
inequalities but i think another
important point is inequalities in
health can be experienced by different
groups of people it might be
the refugees it might be the homeless it
might be people with a
diagnosed mental health problem for
example
and
we often
when looking at trafford data in
comparison with greater manchester might
assume that it's not so much of an issue
for us in trafford because we have good
health outcomes in comparison with gm as
a general rule
but when we look at those internal
differences
in the health outcomes within the
borough between equality groups and
between our affluent and deprived areas
that's when those health inequalities
can look quite stark and just to give
one example life expectancy
generally good in trafford but those
inequalities between the
most affluent and most deprived that are
depicted on slide seven where the
scattergrams are just show that stark
social gradient much higher life
expectancy in our affluent areas
when i looked at those scattergrams the
first question i asked was what is that
dot in the top
left corner um where the life expectancy
is uh particularly
uh low and the deprivation is high
and i i can tell you that is partington
so not too surprising
and within trafford we know that some of
the biggest impacts we can have on
health inequalities will be by reducing
smoking uh alcohol use physical
inactivity and obesity and improving the
mental health of the population that's
why those are our priorities in our
health
in our health and wellbeing strategy
and in fact in trafford diseases
associated with those risk factors
contribute to most of the difference in
life expectancy between those affluent
and disadvantaged areas
so what are we doing about it i think
it's fair to say we're attacking it from
all angles we're doing a lot um and
there's quite a few examples in the
slide set i'll just pick out a couple of
the models um
on slides 10 and 11. um so the first of
those is those uh building blocks um
which highlight
those socio-economic factors and when we
work with those we can narrow our gap by
creating the conditions
across all our neighborhoods
in trafford for people to flourish
and then the
model on
slide 11 is that neighborhood model that
tom mentioned earlier and it's really
got early intervention and prevention at
its heart
it's very much about keeping people
healthy in communities and when they
need services ensuring equitable access
and the right care
in the right place at the right time
i also want to highlight
the outcome of the recent review of the
health and well-being board that tom
also mentioned
and to reiterate that going forward it
is going to have an even greater focus
on reducing health inequalities and to
that end we've planned a series of deep
dive exercises focusing on those
priorities of the health and well-being
strategy that i mentioned earlier and we
can have the greatest impact on reducing
health inequalities if we take a whole
system approach with those system
leaders and really
home in on some of the
wicked issues so for example we've got
really low smoking rates in trafford
overall but the gap between the smoking
rate in our routine and manual workers
and the general population is widening
it's going the wrong way what can we do
about that as a system
been looking at the recent obesity data
for children
nationally we're seeing it increasing
and the gap widening and unfortunately
we're seeing the same in trafford and
what can we do about that as a whole
system
i'm going to hand over to naomi now to
talk about the nhs planning guidance and
some of the nhs models okay thank you
sorry sharon i realized i didn't
introduce myself the last time i spoke
so people might not know who i am i'm
now i'm elaborating for two more days
i'm the director of commissioning for
trafford ccg
so i just want to um
explain the the importance around
inequalities from an nxs and nhs
perspective so the nhs planning guidance
challenges us to tackle inequalities and
and it's it's focuses in us in a couple
of ways which are outlined in um slide
17 and 18
so we we need to respond and um show
that we are focusing and reducing
inequalities in eight key areas
and we will be monitored in that and
benchmarked against other localities to
make sure we're doing well so it's about
protecting the most vulnerable from
covid and restoring nhs services
inclusively the digital image enablement
acceleration of prevention mental health
support particularly post covert in the
and the growing demand and using
information and data to be able to
monitor inequalities and collaboration
and i hope you can hear and what tom
presented today and some of the other
things we've talked about that's thread
through all our strategies and what
we're working on in terms of our
governance and and the priorities we
work on
we're also um asked to work on um
the core 20 plus five
which is designed to support ics's and
really focusing in on really practical
things that you can do
so the the core 20 is focusing on the
most and 20 most deprived population and
engaging and understanding what's um
driving the wider determinants of health
there
but also um focusing on population
groups which have poor outcomes um than
than the average um population
particularly around
maternity and some population groups
within that severe mental illness
chronic obstructive pulmonary disease
early diagnosis of cancer and
hypertension so we've got bits of
frameworks that kind of tell us where we
should be looking we need to change
about what we do and how we do it so
it's not a one-size-fits-all
commissioning or transformation approach
so we're working through the governance
that um tom has described to to put into
place a framework for um tackling
inequalities and how we we support our
transformation
and
so really data driven so looking to see
what the information that our public
health colleagues are telling us about
where those wider determinants are
having an impact on the population
listening to the patient voice working
through the engagement and the
communications work stream to understand
why so not doing maybe what we've
traditionally done and guessed why and
put an answering but actually really
listening to people and making a
difference
and and then looking at existing
services and making sure that they're um
monitored in a way that they are um
supporting reduction of inequalities so
like restoring nhs waiting lists etc
making sure that we're not widening
inequality gaps and within that
and news news services having a
framework that makes sure that we ask is
this going to decrease
inequalities rather than what we
probably traditionally asked is this
going to cause any inequalities and we
will have to get into the conversation
about maybe disproportionate funding in
different areas based on the needs of
the population because we only have a
finite resource both in terms of staff
and in terms of finance as well and then
the wider determinants and i'm going to
repeat some of the stuff that jill has
just said so that's about working with
our partners so that's what the the
provider collaborative is there for um
starting to make all of us and down's
been very good at getting me to thinking
this way you know not just always
talking about health but talking about
health and well-being and widening that
and not always going to the medical
model
but thinking about the prevention and
what we can do with the population and
that's very much embedded in our
neighborhood model that we're working on
as well so there's the the information
about what we need to do and we're
starting to subtly and emerge and change
about how we actually do our
transformation i have to say it's a new
skill for everybody to be able to think
in that way and it also puts challenges
in in um in place as well because you
know i can imagine the debates in the
future here about disproportionate
funding based on um needs of populations
and how we work through that and how we
do that fairly um and then also you know
if you look at our provider colleagues
who have got current pressures around
waiting lists etc you know the pressure
to kind of do that in time order from
how long people have been waiting as
opposed to if there's a population need
as well so it's a very different way of
looking at things and and
we'll learn together as we start to
enact that and then support our teams
and our clinicians to be able to can get
the skills to be able to do that well
i don't know whether you've got anything
else you want to add in july no
so we'll stop there and take any
questions
okay thank you
councillor brophy
thank you for the presentation and all
the information you shared my question
is just looking at the
graph of inequalities and it was
mentioned that really high one in
partington there and we can probably as
word counselors guess what some of the
other ones
are there as well and looking at the
core 20 plus
and looking at those sort of five areas
that you've identified as to where you
can make the most difference and the 20
population figure that's a national
figure so my question is how do you
link those together so in other words
we've got the ward data of where the
inequalities are but are those
inequalities in the key clinical areas
evenly spread or might you find for
example that sort of severe mental
illness has a different spread of area
and perhaps um cancer diagnosis is
different or do you find that each of
those five areas pretty much is the same
as the um
you know the start data in terms of life
expectancy
thank you great question um and
you're right very often they are going
to overlap
and we for example see you know
that
low life expectancy in partington but we
also see some quite poor outcomes around
early diagnosis for cancer which was one
of the uh plus five in the nhs model so
in a community like partington there's
a a really good synergy
and
i want to mention the
part of the neighborhood model which is
about developing neighborhood plans
because that will allow us to um
look obviously at our neighborhood level
data
alongside some of the outcome data that
we have for those target patient groups
and we'll be able to identify hopefully
in each of the four neighborhoods what
are the key priorities where we think we
can have the greatest impact on health
inequalities in the north in central etc
and we're just embarking on that process
and we're going to be pulling all of
those data sources together to try and
get a holistic picture
[Music]
please can i ask her through the chair a
follow-up question so given that you've
explained how the um
health inequality
areas are similar depending on for each
of those conditions those indices
and is it therefore easier to target the
resources and the way you've described
because
well there is in terms of to change
where you're targeting the resources
differently
what are those resources are the
resources staff
are they kind of
waiting lists um what are the ways where
you can kind of target things
differently to to make the differences
that you've explained
so that that's the challenge and that
that will need discussion and scrutiny
and further further updates it it's it's
a bit like the discussion we've just had
about altering the minor injuries is the
need greater in altering them than it is
in the north of
north trafford getting right in locality
and we need to kind of show that need
and be brave enough to be able to put
our resources where actually and the
need is and and it is around workforce
um
we've discussed about access to emps etc
the right type of workforce there and it
is about finance as well
um so we have
to work to get the ideal pathways to get
the really good clinical practitioner
input into understanding what are the
right things to do
based on the feedback that we've got
from our information and our population
and then we need to work to do that in
the fairest way with it with the
resources we have and it is really
challenging it's really difficult and
it's a supporting committees like this
that you know help us do that in the
right way
thanks chair
um
i probably
would pour a little bit of cold water
over
over this um
report in a sense that
since i've been a counsellor
you know this subject
how you actually
you know
provide that equality
um
all the things that
make that gap
is
all the things that you've written down
and that's been written down for years
and years and years
and
i've had this discussion for years and
years and years
and
i remember the health action zones that
you know sprung up and these points been
exactly the same
points that was made there
and
i just wonder and my question is
why will this plan
be more successful than all the other
plans over the years
i'll answer that and you can come in
great question
i suppose we have to say see it as a
glass-half-full approach that the fact
that
we're going through all these changes in
the nhs about bringing commissioning and
provider
closer begging health and social care
closer we've not had those conditions
before really so we're bringing the
energy from um
all of the nhs together with all of
social care
we also i think there's the
accountability within the nhs is
probably stronger than it's been before
in terms that we have to demonstrate
this through the ics that we're we're
delivering this and previously it wasn't
within um
the contracts etc of providers to be
able to reduce inequalities of just
something that we work together on
whereas this is a bit more mandated as
well
and i think we've probably got
the environment to do it better as well
so we have more digital connectivity to
be able to source the information and
we're able to speak to our populations a
little bit more and understand that and
and put it into the uh the changes we
need to um work together on
but it will
feel like previous ones if we don't
collaborate and work together and make
it a priority and be held accountable
about and moving it forward
i'm not jill i might want help to that
sorry
well i completely agree with what you
say there naomi i do think that we do
have some great opportunities at the
moment in time in terms of integration
in terms of
those
opportunities to integrate data more
effectively however
i also think that the challenge is
possibly greater than it has been uh for
decades given the impact of the pandemic
on inequalities and we have to be
realistic that at place level there is
only so many of those wider determinants
those levers that we can actually
have a meaningful impact on and
sometimes
given that
our kind of stretch target our ambition
is to just halt the widening um which is
you know not where we would want to be
but
it is the reality of the economic
circumstances we find ourselves with the
living crisis
we all know don't we that it's not just
about health and social care
it is about employment it's about
education it's about
environment it's about poverty
basically
and
you know it's how we actually break
cycles of that poverty that that is the
determinant of
whether you will
you know have a healthy life or you
won't and i'm not quite sure
that
we're at that place and it is not just
the health and social care that will
solve
this it is government that will solve
solve that poverty
and
once we solve that poverty
um
and and that people have different
decent places to live
and communities that they can live in
then that's when you will start bringing
down that health inequalities not you
know
um
it's this high level
for us to discuss it in this room it's
actually there out on the ground really
and things like sure start and
and
um all of those kind of provisions
that will make the difference
anyway i i am a big supporter of trying
to do this
and i've been trying to tackle it for
for many many years so um you know
good luck
okay dave's ending on a positive there
so
cancer
akinola thank you um mine's a similar
vein it moves from what councilor acton
has said um looking at areas
particularly the north because i'm
interested in the north more so than the
other areas and so there's things like
um child poverty is about 24
and um income deprivation households are
20
in clifford ward and with the impact of
the pandemic and the
the rising costs
i'm sure that's going to have a a
massive increase on um
people's lives and therefore their
mental health and it impacts on
everything else like housing education
everything
and i just wonder has there been any
estimates of what you think that might
rise to and how's that going to impact
the inequalities and gap that we've
already got
when
those levels of poverty
go in that way not that way
not to put you on the spot tom sorry so
no it's okay and it's only a very
generic comment actually but it was one
i was going to come in on before so i
think from a local perspective um when
it's done on council accidents at a
particular point i think it's a local
position we're in a better position than
others where we've spent a dedicated
amount of time over the last say six to
eight months doing work and people in
this room will be fully involved within
the development of the poverty strategy
and which again has been through all our
systems governance owned and presented
to the locality board for that shared
ownership of that poverty strategy
realizing the the importance of that and
absolutely broadening health and social
care i think importantly as well the
development and hopeful sign off in the
coming weeks and months around the
volunteering community and again the
importance of the sector in in terms of
health and social care and their pivotal
role in tackling health inequalities as
well
so i think on a local perspective the
emergence of those two key strategies
are really really um a real positive
that we can build on but in terms of the
specifics around data and intelligence
jill are might be better place to answer
that
yeah just to answer that i'm not aware
of any local analysis that estimates the
trajectory of that increase in terms of
poverty
at a neighborhood level um i i would say
that of all the determinants of health
inequalities poverty is the most
important one um so
i think you know it's
it's certainly very positive that we've
got those two corporate priorities and
i think that if we can address those as
a whole council as a whole system in a
joined up way
really recognizing the impact of poverty
on health outcomes and and health
inequalities
and making sure that we are introducing
what measures we can to mitigate that
impact
through reallocation resources through
you know the understanding we can get
from the data um that you know that's uh
that's very positive um but
you're right it's going in the wrong
direction at the moment
can i just another little question was
how do we improve the
inequalities when access to services is
still so difficult for so many people so
just getting to see a gp getting a day
off work to see a gp getting the money
to go to a hospital appointment when
anecdotally i know there's lots of
people don't go to appointments because
they haven't got the time they haven't
got the money and also the fear of what
they're going to be told when they get
there i'm guessing all this will impact
on those inequalities um
i'm not looking for any solutions here
but
it's um those are those things being
considered in the in the data as well
so
i think it's difficult to give an
absolute answer to that but i think
that's what i mean by
when we start to talk to the population
and the people about why they can't
access services so the data can kind of
drive us down to it's a specific
population group or it's a specific area
and we start to understand how we can
bespoke services a lot more
i mean it goes without saying the
challenges that are going to be
associated with that you know how do we
do that disproportionate funding how do
we support people to do that how do we
have different access points but i think
the starting point is is to change from
doing a one-size-fits-all
to really listening to those population
groups and
working with them about how we could
improve those situations and then
figuring out in that collaborative
approach through our provider
collaborative how do we do that
which is going to be a challenge but
we're always up for a challenge aren't
we to make things happen so
counselor mrs young
this is absolutely taking me back i
don't know how many years i mean when i
was on the health committee
previously with counselor lloyd this is
something we were looking at
and it's it's quite clear the thing is
that
worries me and it worries me now and it
worried me then is more or less what
counsel acton and counselor canelo have
just come out with we actually know
where the
pockets of inequalities are in trafford
the thing is when you when you set down
to
to address them to solve the problem
if you're doing something you're
bringing in some system to improve what
you're delivering in
any particular
branch of of whatever you're doing
you're helping the people who need it
but you're also benefiting the people
who don't need it because they're
benefiting from it in the same way
what i'm trying to say is i don't know
whether it's even possible to do
but can you not come up with some system
whereby you could actually challenge
positively the help that is needed in
the areas only where they are actually
needed i mean portington is definitely
one old trafford i think was a novel or
clifford i mean those are whole areas
now there are pockets of places
in other areas i mean i'm
counsellor for hail central and hail
certainly
in the majority of the people in hale
are by no manner of means deprived but i
can think of little
little groups
in my ward where actually there is the
poverty there
little groups of
people who are still in the
the equivalent or the housing trust
houses or maybe elderly and so
you don't want to
disqualify the people who are in
areas such as this on the other hand
do you see where what i'm trying to go
to i don't know whether it's possible to
sort of
have some system of improving things to
one section of people without going
barrel wide which could make it form too
expensive for everything i don't know
whether it would even be allowable
i think that's the ambition in a
nutshell really to be honest is is to
have the resource and the support where
it's needed to improve the health
outcomes
to do that though we'll be working
within the finance resource in terms of
finance and staffing that we have and
and we'll have to work to make sure we
don't
in a inadvertently disadvantage in other
areas so i think in a nutshell that's
exactly what we want to do
and it's about getting the intelligence
about where those areas are because i
can think of those areas in heel as well
so you you know you could you could
picture that off the top of your head
about where you would go and have the
conversations find out what the issues
are for that population and see what you
could do differently but making sure you
can
do that within the finances and the
resources that you have because we we
haven't got a whole lot of money that's
coming down centrally to say you can
then target
and health inequalities we've we've got
to do it with what we've got at the
moment and redesign but you're
absolutely right that's the ambition to
reduce the inequalities
okay thank you
i've got a few speakers listed and the
next one is uh ben hartley
thank you jay it it follows on really
from from what council mrs young was was
asking about uh
i i i haven't been around as long as as
kendra attend has or i suspect
i'm silly younger as
yeah i didn't like to say chad
but um
but i think i understand their sense of
frustration that we've been talking
about this for many years
and and that that things haven't changed
that much and uh
i mean i agree with council arts and
that this is about
uh this is about poverty it's about
inequalities in a lot of arenas um
intercourse in housing access to open
space and
you can see you can see those
differences in the north and south of
the borough and you know inequalities in
in opportunities as well um
i used to be a governor of primary
school in old trafford and
they took the key stage two children
swimming
and a quarter of the kids that they took
had never seen a swimming pool
um
you could go around you know any any
school and looking lunch boxes and that
would be a pretty good indicator as to
whether those children were living in
poverty and what sort of health they
were likely to enjoy or not enjoying
their future life so
so i guess my question is that
how do we
how do we as a committee
um
assess the
success
um or not of reducing health
inequalities obviously
you know the headline would be those
scattergrams that we've got and you'd
see the dots all converge you know in a
smaller area but i'd imagine that that
will take you know take time and
well it's taking a long time already as
cancer acts and says then we probably
haven't seen those dots converge that
that much so
as a committee what what else should we
be
looking for i suppose to judge whether
we're being successful here or not and i
guess
just following on from what council mrs
young
said um
do you think there are some
hard decisions to make well induced
litter are hard decisions to make here
but i guess um
what i'm struggling with is is how we do
this without disadvantaging some of the
population in trafford because we have
limited resources um
we're not like to see a huge injection
of funding anytime soon i wouldn't have
thought so
for example if you if you're talking
about annual health checks for people
who smoke annual health checks for
diabetics
um that takes more stuff time so there's
an argument then isn't there for
saying that gp practice in the in the
north alberta should be better stuff
than in the south of the borough um they
should have smaller patient lists so
that they can spend the time improving
the health outcomes for those
for those patients um
but i imagine that wouldn't go down well
with residents in hell central ashton
the south of the bureau because you'd be
saying to them
actually you might need to wait long
longer to see your gp you might need to
wait longer for a cancer diagnosis so
how how do we
how do we are those the sorts of
decisions that we are going to have to
make do you think to see movement on
this and
what sort of
factors what sort of things she would be
looking at to
assess whether we're going in the right
direction or not
thank you
another brilliant question
and i think there's probably a
combination between jill and i i think
we do need to have sets of measures in
terms of those longer term outcomes and
jill is much more qualified than i am
tends to that because it does take years
to shift the dial
i think
as we start to pinpoint down where the
inequalities are and what are our
priority areas because we haven't
presented that to you today we've we've
told you what we need to do
and we need to be set in the ambition of
what we want to try to do and have
measures against that and then we will
have to take decisions about how do we
drive those things forward and i think
in terms of that we we need to look at
the equality impact because we we need
to improve the health of the population
for those that have more inequalities
but we don't want to be doing it in
terms of um of disadvantaging other
people as well so i think it's about
pinpointing where we want to look at
being really clear what our clinical and
practitioners say are the the right
things we need to do for those
populations listening to the voice
and then and having an ambition of what
we want to achieve and then if that does
mean disproportionate funding or moving
things around or doing things
differently that we're really clear and
transparent about why and what we're
doing and then also measure that and
look and be held accountable to make
sure what we said we were going to do
happens really so i don't know jilly you
want to add anything into that
i'll just say a bit about the measures
because we do have a number
of intermediate and proxy measures
obviously we're not going to shift the
dial on life expectancy differences
quickly but we can see quick
improvements on things like
uptake of health checks for people with
a serious mental illness uh improved
cancer screening in the neighborhoods
where we know that
the uptake is low so
we can show some of that interim
improvement actually quite quickly and
if for example we're able to narrow that
gap in uh smoking prevalence between
routine and manual and the general
population you'll see that in health
outcome improvements within a couple of
years so yeah
there are um indicators uh within the
corporate plan for health inequalities
and there are indicators associated with
the planning guidance as well
so
i think it's just coming to me i think
it's as well
a couple of made the point it's wider
than health and social care so it's
about making sure that
um the linkages which jill and the team
are trying to pull together through the
living well in my community approach but
that we link into our housing sector we
link into our education sector and
we kind of
make sure that the committees that are
responsible for for them are linked into
the work that we're doing here in health
scrutiny because it's only by all the
partners coming together that we will
make the difference
uh councillor sophie taylor
thank you very much um
you
um you've identified that
data gathering data is is the key to
identifying what problems are are you
able to just expand on that a little bit
more about the sort of nature of the
data is it all quantitative data or
do you have plans to gather some
qualitative data you talked about really
speaking to
uh populations i'm thinking in my own i
represent clifford ward as well and i
recognize that with it it's a very
diverse population
quite a transient population some
members
of the community there are probably
quite difficult to reach how are you
planning on you know thinking about
maybe you know some of the parents of
those children at old trafford primary
school you know how how you who probably
suffers from terrible health
inequalities
how are we going to really sort of hear
their voices and their needs
thank you
jillian can answer it i think in terms
of the information and i will hand over
to tom about the the comms and
engagement approach because it links
into what he's just mentioned before
about the bsca etc
and so just very quickly and and we are
at a point in time with the development
of our engagement approach but all the
partners have committed through we have
a working group um which been in place
for 12 months
with all of the um partners you would
expect across health and social caring
through humanity gmh the voluntary
sector pcns we have dwp on there
we're currently in the sort of um
exploration phase around what a new
engagement model would look like and
that being a core part of our system
governance um right through into
decision making within the locality
board so that anything that gets decided
or discussed has that public voice and
that sits alongside that quantitative
data so we have both qualitative and
quantitative data in order to then start
making those difficult decisions on what
we may or may not do
in any kind of service transformation
and it is quite early stages we have
hopefully um secured some sort of
resource to make that piece of work
happen and happen faster and but again i
think we are the only system having had
conversations at the greater manchester
level with commons and engagement leads
and with the leader to greater
manchester level around coming together
as a system
there are lots of really good practice
within the organizations that make up
the health and social care system in
terms of mft in terms of mastercard the
council has its own approach so does the
ccg and so on and so forth and and i
think at the moment that exploration has
led us to believe that there is probably
a missing forum there that can influence
decision-making and bring that public
voice to the fore um that our
expectations is we want that model sort
of um explored and some options placed
back into the system by the end of this
calendar year with a view to trying to
get something in place um soon after but
still very much in the exploration phase
thank you can i ask a supplementary
question through yourself chat
how can we as well counsellors help with
that process
so we would love you to and we'd really
like your involvement uh we've had some
really
productive conversations of late and
i've literally just had one today with
colleagues in in mft colleagues of
john's um and and they're proving really
fruitful um but i think
what counselors would bring to this is a
completely different dimension and it
plays back to the point i forgot who
mentioned it before about that sharing
of intelligence from the ground up and i
do think jill will probably want to come
in on this
but the emergence of that neighborhood
model and that multi-disciplinary team
that spans the boundaries of just health
and social care but brings in education
that brings in the private sector that
brings it and the general public i think
has to have that route all the way
through up until decision making as a as
i tried to describe before so um if
that's a an offer of support i will
gladly take it
i can't speak for all of my colleagues
but i think um
i think we would definitely want to work
with you
that'd be really helpful thank you can i
just add to that then in terms of the
development of the neighborhood plans um
we do want um elected member involvement
in that and we also i completely agree
with you i think we need to be not only
looking at the quantitative data but
complementing it with patient voice and
also citizen voice
and so
my idea really is that we need to
triangulate those sources of data but i
think you make a really important point
that it's harder to hear the voices
probably of the people who are at
greatest risk in terms of inequalities
and so again it's about distributing our
resources accordingly and actually we're
going to need to work harder in some
communities or to reach some communities
than others and i think we now need to
decide you know that that's where we put
our resource in terms of engagement
um we do still have the engagement
workers that
were stood up as part of the
covid response and we say we have one
option is to deploy them but it's a
small team so we need to identify
additional resource to make sure that
we are able to meaningfully um listen to
the stories of of people who are you
know very much at um
well
i guess feeling the impacts in terms of
health inequalities within communities
so that's that's the direction of travel
and i think it's a challenge for us
thank you and uh councillor jane brophy
thank you for coming back to me and some
of my questions have been answered in
the course but i just wanted to
reflect on something that
like counselor acton
and i've been around on this committee
for quite a long time and not recently
but certainly tackling health
inequalities is something both
professionally and as a counsellor i've
been involved in for kind of more
decades and i care to think about
probably
yeah
um so i certainly identify with what
council acton was saying and the shore
start centers were
one of those unique interventions that
actually was wanting to directly change
i used to work for the
shore start centers so i had quite a
strong passion for them at the time
because it was my my job to work there
and i also think there's some other
really valid points that people have
made and councillors laters about
outcomes that's really important because
i've gathered from the presentation
you've given that the outcomes are
actually getting worse so rather than
closing the gap or actually increasing
the gap
and i do feel in this field of work i
admire your optimism and upbeatness
because
i think sometimes in my professional
work as well sometimes um
you feel like all you're really doing is
stopping people getting worse the
professional feel i work on and you know
every now and again you get a great
success story and someone turns the life
around that's really wonderful and
heartening when you see that individual
story where someone does actually turn
the life around but more often than not
the professionals involved tend to just
kind of stop things getting worse
so i think that's where we're at with
with this type of work
and and i do relate to council young's
point as well is when you do kind of
start redistributing resources in the
way that you've described you can
accidentally maybe have
inadvertent consequences so you might
kind of
put lots of money and resource into
particular areas which will obviously be
welcome for those
groups but it might be that that
resource
at the end of the day doesn't make that
much difference to those people which
there's some evidence that's the case
that just throwing money at things
doesn't always turn things around unless
it's targeted like the shore start
centers were in that particular way
but on the other hand it might cause
people who are perhaps living in poverty
in the more affluent areas of trafford
say you know in the old tomb area that
council are young and those people have
a you know inadvertent effects on the
health because they can't get the
appointments the services they were used
to because all the resources have gone
elsewhere
i can think of things like sort of with
appointments in hospitals so for example
i know the service i work in and that
there is it's very difficult to get
people to come for appointments nowadays
telephone appointments video
appointments face-to-face we've got the
full range but people are just not
attending appointments probably because
life's
difficult now i did have an idea
that and it links in with um
the other question we had around um
getting the patients the stories not the
patient stories but the the um people in
the communities getting their stories
because in traffic we're very lucky we
have a lot of voluntary organizations
community groups faith groups we're very
strong on those kind of
community people who want to do things
and quite often i think in the south of
the borough
there are more people who've got that
time available to
do something good in the community is
there any scope for say like getting
people in the south of the borough to
maybe the volunteer groups maybe some
twinning or something like that maybe
clifford or partington could twin with
groups in sort of um my area timperley
or hale or somewhere so that maybe it
could be faith groups pairing together
or
um friends of parks group pairing
together and like a bit like you have
twin cities so to speak so you pair the
group so maybe
the more well-endowed areas can support
the less well-off areas it might be like
somebody mentioned about appointments
that in clifford ward that often people
aren't attending hospital appointments
because they can't get the time off work
even if they get a gp appointment which
might be you know how do they get the
time off work without losing
vital income to buy food for the
children those types of things
how we're going to get i think the
question is about
maybe if we can sort of look at
doing creative things and engaging the
voluntary sector is is the thought i've
got thank you
it's okay come back on that chat and so
i i think it is a really good idea i do
think we have to think differently about
this um
and as you were you were talking then
and
the first thing that came into my head
was the work we've done recently on the
letting of the the new volunteering
community and faith and social
enterprise sector infrastructure
contracts which we're currently going
through a co-production um six months to
try and define what that contract will
um
will be and when it comes into effect in
in october and really glad to say that
both trafford community collective if
people are familiar with the community
collective i'm sure most of you will be
um and thrive who would the existing
contracts holders have joined in a
partnership to to deliver that contract
and so i think there's an opportunity to
shape the support that we can put into
the sector to enable maybe an idea such
as what you've described um
in the future i think it links into
conversations on volunteering um and the
strategy that's in place and the again
the capacity and the focus on
volunteering within that particular um
within that particular contract
but i actually think
the
that's the word i'm looking for the sort
of the
the usp the unique selling point of the
community collective is it's what i
perceive to be it's unbelievable reach
into communities if it has a that
growing membership which it has um the
ability to to connect with people in all
different walks of life um in all
different parts of trafford um using
their league members across the four
different neighborhoods which align with
the neighborhood model which naomi and
myself and jill are all spoken about i
think that is a really
fantastic opportunity and one that i
don't think we've had before and
potentially others may
tell me otherwise but certainly not
since my time back in trafford for the
second time so i think that's a
fantastic opportunity it's something we
can take forward as an action and
explore as part of that cross-production
phase of of the new contract but i think
also working with george as the as the
chair i think that might be his
uh official title of the community
collective but we can definitely pick
that up with him and george represents
the the sector on all our partnership
boards alongside heather um as well from
healthwatch obviously
[Music]
um
and it's nice that you see their
enthusiasm so i i've sat on here with
yourselves for a while now
and i share your frustration as do i
know all the team do
um and we want to be absolutely frank
with you we are we have a perfect storm
don't we we've got um
a worldwide pandemic which is really set
back the dials that we're moving in some
areas particularly like stopping smoking
in our manual workers were starting to
reduce really nicely all shifting back
because people are really stressed by
all of what's gone on we've then got the
the economic recession that is going to
hit us very very hard for our residents
so you are right to be concerned i share
that and you are right to hold us to
account what i've asked the team to do
is look at a set of dials with realistic
ambitions because we've got to be
realistic haven't we
maybe holding the position is the first
target but then starting on the areas
that are easiest to uh to manage
i think the population um
and how
lots of members have raised this how
they're impacted locally is the key to
working differently we've got to do it
differently because what we've tried and
people have tried really hard
isn't getting the traction we need or
want
and so a very different approach that's
described which really goes to the heart
of that conversation with residents
um through our public health work and
we're moving a lot of our funding into
the prevention and if we can
particularly around public health
funding linking that to the health and
wellbeing board review which we've had
the local government association to
support us with very targeted piece of
work and we cannot
tell you definitely that this will shift
aisles and at this speed but we have to
have a strong ambition and and will
which they definitely have and i'm glad
you've
you know you've spotted that um but with
a dose of realism that we are facing a
tide a tidal wave i would say of
pressure coming through the system the
other thing i think for members to
consider um one and worries me quite a
lot is because of the way that we
present in the data and you might
be able to clarify some of this really
we appear if you take the borough as a
whole to be in a relatively good
position and therefore
impacts on funding allocations could be
impacted and i think for members that is
something just for you to
note and keep challenging on maybe
nationally but also locally that we
funnel as much as we can into the
prevention activity and use all the
resources that we're spending anyway on
services to make sure that we're picking
up on issues a bit like the children's
work making every contact count is
really essential isn't it whenever we're
seeing something that we pick up on
those issues
and so i i just think it is you know the
dose of realism the pressure's on it's
going to get worse we're doing our best
but but it's a big it's a very very big
dial to move some of this thank you
chair
thank you
councillor shona gilbert
[Music]
um most of my questions have now been
answered but just one um tiny one which
was about measurement and i think on the
core 20 plus five you did mention there
were some government targets and
measurements i just wondered what those
would be and um when we might be able to
to see those throughout the coming year
so
i would have thought by the the end of
the summer
not even i would have thought we need to
by the end of summer because we've got
to be able to report that back up
central i so if you tom's got to open
there in front so i can i can just read
it but it's you know it's about case
binding of people with hypertension so
we we need to be able to look at the
information on our gp
systems identify
those people that will be at risk and
have a an ambition about what we should
be targeting so we will we will have to
submit where we're at in all of those
areas
and it's october the um this year but we
need to be taking that through our
health and wellbeing board as well so
it'll need buy-in and support
particularly from our gp colleagues and
being able to search their systems and
and look at it and then also from
our acute colleagues as well because
there's maternity access in there as
well for specific groups
some of the stumbling blocks we might
have is some of the information being
recorded in terms of um the demographics
to be able to do that and we need to put
some um
we've we've started to put some
underpinning stuff into gp practices to
help and support them uh recording that
information and i know acute trust have
been working on that for quite a while
as well to be able to do it so we you
know future meetings of this will not be
us talking about what we're going to do
it'll be
this is the work we're doing and these
are the measures that we're trying to
push the dialogue
council judith lloyd
um
you've had engagement strategies um ccg
pct pcg whatever
i've been around a long time
i just
can you use that data because things the
only thing that's changed
um as far as i can see there's so there
will be some demographic changes
but as council acting rightly point out
nothing's uh changed old trafford
um a clifford board particularly um
partington we know where the areas of
deprivation are they haven't changed
um can't you use some of that data to
try and get some quick wins
because i do realize health inequalities
is a
a very long process
and
and i agree with diane in the fact that
things are going to get worse there's a
recession coming up
and i think it's very sad
at the moment that people have got to
choose between heating and eating
and
about 30 years ago i visited i used to
have to visit over 75
and this lady put um i went to her house
it was absolutely freezing she put the
heating on for me and i think those are
the choices
so where's what's changed in that time
um
really um which is why i'm a bit
share some of your cynicism but
recognize that we we have got to change
things for the people who are in in
poverty
except it's going to get worse for them
and i know somebody said about the
trajectory you can't
predict but you can at the moment
it's
people
particularly children in poverty it's
not going down it's going up
older people um are suffering as well
and it's also those people who are
actually in work
who are earning
but are actually having to worry about
the heating bills their food bills their
mortgages and everything else so to me
it's just
you know
how
what difference can you make and when
can you tell us when you have made that
difference
as quickly as possible
so i think you're right counselor lloyd
in in terms of we know where it is we we
don't have to go back to scratch to
understand what's in the joint um
strategic needs assessment i think when
we're talking about engagement it's
about the the how we solve it
so the really talking to the individuals
about and the populations about what is
it we can do differently
and then
sorry to repeat myself again but it's to
them have those challenging
conversations so how do we get
with the finite resources we have of
workforce and and finance how do we get
the collaboration between everybody at
deliver services to be able to support
tackling those inequalities
so i i think that's the thing that's
different
believe it or not i know i look very
young but i've been around for quite a
long time as well um
we've never quite had the place where
we've had everybody together and coming
through the locality board and the
membership of it to be able to try to
make those changes and you you know me
quite well that i'm always very glass
half full of trying to kind of make
things happen
but i do think that collaboration and
bringing people together and the
the accountability is is the bit that's
different we're not going to spend ages
trying to understand we know it's
partlington we know it's the pockets and
simply we know it's the pockets and heel
barns etc but actually
what's the inequality they're facing in
terms of health and um and what's the
driver and what can we do to be able to
to support that and then can we bring
the rest of the system along with this
and i think we've got because we've got
the locality board now
if if we get to a point where we
understand all that but we can't get
ourselves to agree to be able to change
what we do to be able to deliver that
then it's it's through our locality
board and through um forums like this
that we need to have those debates um
not withstanding and council brought
face point of uh we need to be looking
at the equality impact
this assessment because we don't want to
be rob and peter to pay paul either
really so i hope that helps it is a real
challenge i'm going to take it on the
chin what you're saying as well but we
will keep trying to make sure it happens
can i just
question that
um
in terms of the engagement
the people who you want to engage
a big part of them
don't want to be engaged because they've
been passed from pillar to post
from service to service and not getting
it
and and it's and and they're the ones
that you you really need
to be able to you know grab and to
engage with
uh and and
obviously you have to be very positive
when you engage
with them and and
actually
open up in in a way to to to failures
that have have gone on within those
communities and it is really difficult
and i want to be positive and i i really
do
but we have to get these things right
when we do it
because if we think
you know
praising us all together because we are
trying to tackle this is not going to be
the answer it is actually getting out
there right deep into the community
before you will
ever make any difference because they've
that they've had that cycle
of
you know deprivation basically and it's
really difficult you know families have
been there and and it's really difficult
people
being made homeless now i had
a call only the other night that
um
this
woman had been evicted with the sun
and had nowhere to go and there wasn't a
place in trafford
and
had to go to bed and breakfast
outside of manchester and she's got a
son who's doing you know her gcse and
it
you know
it's heartbreaking when when when you
hear that and
and see that
poverty and i know that you all know
that and and you know i'm not i'm not
having a go at you or anybody in this
room because i know that everybody's
hearted in exactly the right
place
and
and i think as diane
said that you know we're in a
really really difficult
period now
it's everything's in crisis quite
frankly you know and i don't know how
we're going to get out of this
um without a change of government quite
frankly but that's a political point
but but you know i think we've got to
get out of that somewhere along the line
okay it comes to taylor
i think i ask my questions didn't i
no i think i was highlighting that
this is in two parts isn't it it's what
the government can do and is able to do
um and we saw the impact of the 20-pound
reduction on universal
credit didn't we and the impact that
that had
and there are the things that we can do
locally
one of the things that i think that we
should be doing and i've been
um
sort of um shouting about this for
several months now
is that um
we need to make sure that people get all
the benefits that they're entitled to i
mean that for me would be a quick win so
for example on healthy start
um my understanding is that only half
the parents have picked up
on healthy starts and i know there are
national figures around
uh big gaps in pension credits for
example and i know pension credits isn't
exactly
anything that's straightforward because
sometimes if you have that you lose on
something else but i do think that if we
could target the um
the areas that we've talked about today
you know maybe with pop-up tents or
marquis or something and if we had
people who are able to actually help
people
er to claim what they are entitled to i
think that that would be um a bit of a
start really
the other thing that we know is that
we've got digital exclusion in 10
of our population
and again there are things that we could
be doing on an education front to try
and enable people to be able to
access the internet
uh the final thing really was about um
that the ics is actually producing a
strategy and every ics has to do and
this will be
produced by um at the end of this year
and there's going to be a large scale
survey going around asking people what
their priorities are
for health and well-being and i think
that should give us
some more information to add into all
the more detailed stuff that we've got
at a neighborhood level
thanks
[Music]
thank you well we've had a lot of uh
really good input there from from the
whole excuse me sorry i think mr morrow
yeah i'm just going to say um
like data has come up a lot during these
conversations and you uh councillor
lloyd spoke about
this has been gone a long time we've got
data from
time and time ago are we able to use
that i think that's one of the key
things that you need to be doing um as
part of all your plans is not just
thinking about gathering the data now
and looking at the impacts now it's
making sure that when you go and do
interventions that you're gathering data
in a way that you can
go back and collect further data from
those people in five in ten years and
look at the impacts that you're having
because this problem's not going to go
away in five years or ten years but what
you can do is ensure that in 10 15 years
you're armed with accurate data which
will then really help you to tackle
these problems in ways that you couldn't
even imagine now
so it's just ensuring that when you're
doing these
interventions that you are gathering
information on a gold standard
[Music]
thank you alexis that's very helpful and
something we need to
keep being mindful of
um so i was saying a lot of really good
um
input there on on a very important
subject to one that's getting more and
more uh important
um i did joke about cancer acting and
this uh
length of service but it but it is does
illustrate the point uh he's um
you know very long serving on this
council so
he is speaking with a lot of experience
um
and um
judith mentioned
looking for some some quick wins um it
might sound a bit of a glib phrase that
but it certainly would help if we could
find some
um
some that uh
deal with uh some some big numbers in a
short space of time um
[Music]
would be would be uh ideal
uh diane mentioned
the perfect storm and
um i don't think it's quite perfect yeah
i think it's um it's still
still building the pressures still
building we've got
um certainly a lot of um young adults in
this borough who are about to
experience new pressures in their lives
that they've never experienced before
different types of pressures but they
are ones that will will cause stress and
strain
um
and
who knows where that where that pops up
uh
so it it
it's a
it's a a frightening picture and it puts
um
even more pressure on on everybody
in this room i think but i think with
what we can take from from tonight um is
is that there is a lot of resolve
here that can be harnessed
and it's
harnessing
um
that
very local resolve and harnessing
resolve across the council um to
to make a difference
uh in in the light of the um
in the new circumstances that that we're
all going to be facing uh very soon
um
so on those sort of
sobering
words um
i'll conclude that item but uh sincerely
thank everybody for their input in that
and so i think we're on item
10
now which is the committee
work program
so the details were in the
um
pack
um this is to consider this well this is
the draft work program but to consider
um
this as the program for the committee
for this municipal year
so it's um
it is draft it can
alter things can be
moved um
i'll just uh
open it up for any thoughts from
from anybody
[Music]
did the last item wear everybody out
with
councillor brophy um as a sort of
returning member of this committee um
a lot of these work streams will already
be sort of in progress
um
and probably some
committee members will have left to go
to other committees etc
how do you sort of allocate the members
of the committee to the work plan if
you've got sort of like um
that they used to be sort of working
groups where people
came together in small groups to look at
things or is it more kind of ongoing and
through the offices
[Music]
well this is the work program for the
committee we've not looked at uh setting
up any
work groups yet and that's something
that we can consider
um
you know where we um
have a good reason to to do so
so um
whether anybody's got any ideas on that
right at this minute or whether it's
something that we can think about and
and discuss again um i don't know
council judith lloyd
can we do something
um all the reports that we get to say to
note to note to note
and is there anything we as the scrutiny
committee can do um a piece of work that
would perhaps feed into
either health or social care happy
to be directed it's just that
i think it's
it's important to show that we are
actually doing work rather than just
noting all the reports
that we get
well
you're absolutely right certainly it
would be my intention this year that we
do
do a bit more than note
i think it's perhaps a little bit the
way the agenda is falling today but um
but certainly i would want a bit more of
a bit more than noting to be to be
happening so um
if we've got any
specific ideas on that
now or or if we want to you know think
about those and um
perhaps circulate some ideas on emails
so that we don't wait months before then
you know until the next meeting before
we do anything
cancer brophy
i did see sophie's hand go up at the
same time
but i just thought you know we here we
are all face to face which is kind of a
new experience compared to what we've
how we've been conducting business over
the last two years but it seems that
we've now got more of a hybrid way of
operating so we've always got the option
to have
um sort of teams meetings i know we used
to have sort of groups of counsellors
from the committee that will come
together on specific themes which are
sometimes difficult if you working and
to get the time to do that but given
that we've now got the some option to do
sort of teams meetings and things is
there an opportunity
for sort of particular counselors to go
and look at particular themes of work
and perhaps sort of
um
you know
thought to each other and come back to
the committee with sort of some ideas to
share
yeah
yeah i mean i think um
we in our committee
um
the the one i chair
and
the children young people have task and
finish groups which
are really really helpful because it
could be a small group of counselors
that can meet when they wish to meet
uh don't don't have to be face to face
and if you pick a couple of
topics you could have
maybe a couple of tasks and finish
groups it's just a suggestion but it
does work really well
because then you can um you know look at
the issue that um
you know the topic is about and and then
you can make recommendations you know
bring people in to that small group
and
um once you've finished it you can make
recommendations to the council or
whoever the body is
uh
in relation to that
fine yeah okay go to taylor
yeah thank you chad i'm just gonna pick
up on that because we actually had
didn't we
a small group of us had a
sort of a pre um
planning planning meeting uh i'm just
gonna ask alex will you just remind us
because i i
um
don't have the record of that meeting in
front of me was just to remind us what
we said at that time because we did
identify exactly what you've just said
dave a few um
ideas for task and finishing i can't
remember what they all are now
there was one suggested around
access to gps
because it was raised at the
back in february by council of blackburn
who's no longer here but it's still a
very valid topic because she was
speaking about the difficulties people
had in booking appointments at gps
following the pandemic like a lot of gps
have a system where you have to ring
precisely eight o'clock and if once the
appointments are filled in they're
filled in and people are just having
real difficulty in getting appointments
so that was something that she suggested
there was one suggested by councillor
lloyd a few a couple of months ago as
well around dentistry in trafford as
manchester just done an in-depth look
at dentistry and suggested doing the
similar in trafford again i think um
it was mainly around access again and
following the pandemic but i don't know
if you want to end anymore well i don't
know i mean
dentistry is
something i think the government have
got to take on
because the access to dentistry i think
across the board is is awful
um and there have been things on things
like facebook about
and in the press about
people not being able to access a
dentist but again it's knowledge as well
there are dentists available but who
knows where
where to go
i do
but i'm not sure somebody
um who lives somewhere else
does so i think
i mean we could look at trafford but i
think it's just the same across the
country we've got the same problems and
i personally think it's a
health and well-being
aspect because actually good dental
health
it means that you have a
good medical health
as well it affects
a lot of
um
systems
you know it's not just your mouth it's
your whole body
[Music]
and then on top of those today um you
had that element earlier where you're
saying about
helping with communication
with the communities that's something
that you could look as a committee to
lead on and how that could be
implemented going forward and work with
tom and others
i think that could be something we could
make real impacts but yeah thank you
okay
um just adding to the list there's one
that jumps out here um it talks about
the deep dive in mental health issues in
terms of the services alcohol substance
misuse the self-referral services is
there something around mental health
because that impacts everything doesn't
it all those health outcomes are all
underpinned by
mental health
just uh i'm getting some good ideas here
i'm just struggling to um think on my
feet as to
that the mental health one it's on the
um
page 21
um
just as the
um and it says the january
submissions i'm just thinking
um
it's like a theme that
um
is quite sort of wide reaching for
all of this committee's work isn't it
okay well to
um
in order to make a bit of progress be
rather than wait until our next meeting
um
is
is
does anybody have an idea of something
that um
such as
that one jane that um we can start
a bit of
work on in the interim
well i think um
we've talked a lot at the committee
about how the
um covert is impacted on people who've
got existing mental health challenges
and also diane's alluded to
the kind of storm that we're all
coming up around kind of people's
um
you know the the poverty and what they
can afford the heat and eat and i think
people struggling with mental health
have particular challenges
in being able to sort of manage their
lives
and
it'll be like a sort of double
inequality if you're already
experiencing mental health challenges
and you struggle with money as well then
it's something that's going to impact
quite badly so it's just kind of
thinking
about
how we can um sort of monitor that if
there's anything there's a scrutiny
committee how we might be able to
given that it's on this agenda here the
health and wellbeing is doing a deep
dive i'm not quite sure
what the outcome of that deep dive is or
whether it's been reported on yet but
i'd be quite keen to kind of get more
information about um how that deep dive
is going
and jerry we could happily prepare
briefing packs there's a lot of work
being done on transforming mental health
and connecting across into children's
mental health as well so i'm sure
colleagues could bear a briefing path
for the task and finish group and then
that might form some of the questions
that you want to drive forward
um
in preparation for i think it's down in
january but in preparation so that the
right questions and the right
information and the right thinking is
coming into the reports in january for
you as well
okay so there's the offer of that
um briefing pack and there's a
willingness to do some
task and finish work
and alex wants to just
just as a way of helping now as part of
the review last year we were coming up
with the selection criteria for um
for topics to hit in order to
go forward with task and finish work so
it's just like a
paper exercise that helps to scope out
what you want to do so
what we could do is
fill those out for the topics that have
been um
suggested here so it's like looking at
what can scrutiny actually do and asking
what is the specific issue you want to
look at and so make sure that when we go
into the work that something delivers
deliverable is going to come out of it
so what i could do is circulate that um
we could
fill those out for those different
topics and then come together virtually
to
look at those again and decide which of
those you'd want to do
in terms of resource you'd be able to
have about two tasks and finish groups
um this year with
officer support
but we couldn't really do more than that
unless you're looking at doing a joint
task and finish group with one of the
other committees
okay and in terms of timing for the two
that we could have officer support for
how soon would the first one be
able to start
you could start them within a couple of
weeks uh i mean it'd just be getting
those uh original scoping documents put
together um
filling them out as much as possible uh
circulating to the committee and then
having a virtual meeting which as um
council broker pointed out we can do
that quite
easy so we could probably start it
within two three weeks
okay
i like the sound of that you wanted to
yeah it was just a couple of points
would it be okay if i liaised with alex
outside about the time because i'm just
thinking about the capacity of the teams
to be able to do the briefing packs as
well as the health and well-being um
board update as well
and then just a point to know in in um
in addition to what councilor lloyd said
at dentistry and
we don't commission dentistry so
actually we haven't got the right people
around the table to be able to support
that in terms of um
a deep dive not saying it's not an issue
but it's just we haven't got the right
officers in the locality
did you want to say something then
i was just going to say a similar point
actually that dentistry is nationally
commissioned isn't it so i do think for
the
task and finish groups um
i think i think alex's
offer is a good one because for the task
and finished groups i think we should
focus on things where we are going to
have
make a difference and have an output i
think where and then dentistry probably
isn't one of those um it doesn't mean we
shouldn't look at it but i think if it's
coming to a meeting so that we can
understand the problem and that
that probably uh does the job uh
yeah i agree with councillor brophy
about about mental health and
we we talk about cams a lot and we
always say oh yeah children young people
scrutiny they're doing some work on that
but i don't i don't know they are i
don't know if anyone's ever checked so i
think you know some joint work on on
cams would be good and uh
and uh my own view is the given some of
the things we've talked about tonight's
meeting the
the access to to gps one is is something
that
might lend itself to a task and finish
group i think particularly
accessing appointments um post pandemic
but also some of the things that we've
talked around about how does that access
differ between north and south alberta
deprived and unless it's like parts of
the barrier yeah
i
agree
exactly with what was said the access to
gps i do think is it's quite important
i mean you can ask for a gps appointment
at eight o'clock in the morning one day
and then wait two or three days for
somebody to bring you back from the
clinic to give you your appointment i
know that for a fact so okay i think we
know
we need to you know we we could look at
it
yeah because we looked at it
pre-pandemic but be very interesting to
see how things have changed over that
time really wouldn't it
so
alex has come up with uh
a structure for a way forward for us and
there's obviously a
mood to to look at that
access to gp's
services
um but we don't need to
we could we should i think we should
still do what you said and and assess
other topics as well but clearly
from what we're hearing around the table
so far that the gp one will emerge
somewhere near the top
so um is is everybody happy to
take it forward that way
fine okay
sorry keep coming in oh i just wonder if
alex would you be willing to um liaise
with the team here you know we said
about maybe working with them to do some
calms and and really sort of get under
the skin of some of our residents you
know
to try and contact and uh communicate
with our residents regarding health
needs so i don't know if that's
something you would be able to
i don't mean you know just liaise with
the team to see how we can practically
do that really
uh yeah what i'll do is i'll just ask
tom to describe what he feels um offer
counsellors could offer and uh then get
you guys in the same room and let you
thrash it out between you okay thank you
thanks so much
okay
and i think we've concluded uh
that matter and there's no urgent
business
um
so we've included what i think has been
a
a very worthwhile meeting and again
thank you to everybody for your
inputs uh into it it's very much
appreciated and
i think it will uh
all of it will serve us well on
the work that we're taking forward so
thank you very much indeed